présent tout le long du front national
madame stirbois la veuve de l'ancien
numéro deux du parti de jean marie le
pen
la participation est également
relativement faible environ 33 % de
votants mais geslin résultats
intéressants sur une estimation ce n'est
pas encore le résultat définitif du
premier tour et bien madame stirbois du
front national donc a failli passer au
premier tour avec 49 0 5% des voix
devant le candidat rpr 19 8% des voix et
le candidat socialiste 15,29 il faut
dire que seul le front national s'était
vraiment montré actif pendant la
campagne
dans un département où l'un atteint 11 %
d'immigrés a droit aujourd'hui en cette
journée d'élection et bien l'ambiance
était tout à fait particulière il y
avait d'un côté ceux qui étaient
concernés les immigrés mais qui ne
votait pas pour la plupart
et puis les autres reportage d'olivier
werner et annick dreux côté face on vote
tranquillement à deux kilomètres de là
le quartier des chats mars et le dreux
côté pile on ignore tout ou presque de
ce qui se passe en ville
l'action il y avait des élections
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes au
courant
non moi je ne sais pas pourquoi je ne
parle pas je travaille apparaît japa
sortait 50 démâtage et intérêts à
hauteur de soi devant le bureau de vote
il passe il se retourne mais il ne
s'arrête pas
sept candidats étaient en lice et une
fois n'est pas coutume certains
électeurs ont annoncé la couleur
j'ai surtout remarqué que depuis que les
front national n'a pas n'est pas dans la
majorité du conseil municipal
la situation s'est dégradée elle allait
beaucoup mieux pendant ces six dernières
années
bon bah ça recommence à se dégrader il
faut espérer que le front national
passera on sait tous les émigrés il ya
une partie qui est bien intégré il ya
qu' il ya une minorité qui fout la
pagaille
cette minorité la sueur pouvait
l'éliminer l'ouest on dire ceux qui sont
là vont pas les rejeter dans la mesure
où effectivement il ya pas mal d'années
on a eu besoin d'eux pour faire tourner
les usines parce que vous êtes une ville
13 ouvrière et
effectivement pas leur fermer la porte à
ceux qui sont déjà en place maintenant
il faut stopper effectivement
l'immigration il faut pas oublier ceux
qui sont là d'ailleurs beaucoup d'entre
eux sont devenus français
je ne suis pas raciste je tiens à le
préciser tout de suite
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai pas
voté front national il tenait à voter
aujourd'hui tout à fait barrage à
l'extrême droite
vous allez voter pour qui
j'ai voté pour un candidat socialiste
politique et arithmétique se conjuguent
ici au présent soixante mille électeurs
inscrits onze mille immigrés à dreux et
dans sa périphérie marginalisés
ghettoïser trois mosquées sont même à
proximité de ces bureaux de vote
mais ici point de cohabitation marie
france stirbois du front national michel
thillier du rpr et claude nespoulous du
parti socialiste se retrouveront donc
dimanche
l'heureuse élue pourra peut-être
apporter une réponse aux questions
qu'elle se pose